We know that Galileo was an amazing experimentalist.
So let's go back to Pisa and repeat his experiment.
[♪♪]
We're back at the Leaning Tower of Pisa,
and we're going to carry out one of Galileo's famous motion experiments.
So we've already bought the equipment. We set up the experiment.
Now, what's left to do is to carry it out.
What I'm going to be doing is rolling this hollow cylinder down this inclined plane.
I've divided this plane into four sections, equally spaced,
and I'm going to be timing how long it takes the cylinder to roll through each section.
So that will require four separate measurements.
Instead of dripping water to measure time, I'm going to be using a piece of equipment Galileo
did not have access to, an app on my cellphone.
We've got our data.
Now, we'll have to repeat this experiment several times
so that we can ensure accuracy then we can analyze.
Now, you're going to do the experiment yourself.
To do this experiment, you're going to need a proper equipment.
So first, you will need something flat and that could be a piece of wood like you just saw me use
or it can even be something as simple as a book.
You're also going to need a measuring device.
This could be a meter stick or a tape measure or anything else that measures distance.
You'll need something to roll, and it should be either spherical or cylindrical,
and you'll need a timing device, something that measures in seconds,
and you can download this or find it in the internet very easily.
Finally, you'll need something to prop your flat object up.
This could just be a book that you stick underneath your flat object
or maybe a piece of wood, it doesn't matter.
Just the purpose is to make this into an incline.
To actually do this experiment, first you're going to need to measure four equally spaced intervals
on your flat object, and actually, it doesn't matter what unit to use.
This could be 1 m or it could be 2 cm as long as you're consistent,
as long as the spacing is the same each time, and you're going to start taking time measurements.
So for each of these four distances, you want to time how long it takes the ball to roll
from the starting point to the end point and actually it's not enough to do this just once for each distance.
You want to repeat each experiment multiple times.
How many? It's up to you. I would suggest four or five.
What you'll then enter into this data table is your average time
and the average deviation of those time measurements.
You'll enter those numbers here since you know now how to compute
averages and average deviations, and then later in the class, we'll do some data analysis
with class the data on these distance measurements.
Note one thing, this experiment is done slightly differently than Galileo did it.
We're not letting the ball roll for a fixed period of time and then measuring the distance.
We're letting the ball roll for a fixed distance up to one or up to two and then measuring the time.
But this isn't equally good way to do this experiment. Good luck!